The internet's boyfriend might be speeding
into one of the biggest movie franchises out
there.
In a recent interview with Screen Rant, long-time
Fast & Furious scribe Chris Morgan revealed
that he has spoken with Keanu Reeves about
joining the film series in an upcoming entry
- presumably Fast & Furious 9, which Morgan
is co-writing with Daniel Casey.
Morgan teased:
"I sat down with him and we're talking about
[it].
I wanted him to be in the Fast universe for
a very long time…The hardest thing is always
time and competing schedules and then designing
the right thing together.
My fervent desire is to bring him into this
franchise for sure."
Morgan has indeed been hoping to make Reeves
an official member of the Fast family for
quite some time, and even got close to making
that dream a reality fairly recently.
In August 2019, Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson
said that Reeves could have been in Hobbs
& Shaw, the Fast & Furious spin-off centered
on Johnson's character Luke Hobbs and his
onscreen frenemy Deckard Shaw, played by Jason
Statham.
The actor told Screen Rant that the original
plan was to have Reeves portray the director
of the terrorist organization Eteon in Hobbs
& Shaw, written by, you guessed it, Chris
Morgan.
As Johnson explained, things just didn't work
out, and so the Hobbs & Shaw team decided
to keep the identity of Eteon's director a
mystery by only revealing his voice.
Johnson dished:
"We left the ominous voice faceless.
So, for some time, I think you guys have heard
the rumor that it was going to be a bit of
a John Wick, all disguised.
But then we left it there [with] a few people
in mind.
Originally, Keanu was the goal.
We were talking, and it just didn't feel right
creatively.
He and I talked, and I totally got it.
And it wound up being the best thing, so now
we leave that open for the future."
Hobbs & Shaw director David Leitch also addressed
the situation in an August 2019 interview
with The Hollywood Reporter.
The filmmaker explained that the team, quote,
"talked to Keanu early on," and that he, quote,
"had been talking to Keanu periodically through
the shooting of it all" and was trying to
decide how best to include him in Hobbs & Shaw.
In the end, though, Hobbs & Shaw just wasn't
the right film to introduce Reeves into the
Fast & Furious franchise.
"Are you ready?"
"Yeah, I'm ready."
"On my three."
"Okay."
"One…"
"AHHH!
YOU..."
Leitch explained:
"I also wanted to make sure that it was enough,
a real promise for something legitimate in
the future, and wasn't just a stunt casting
role.
We started to populate the movie with all
these other personalities, and I just didn't
really think that we needed it, although I
would've loved it.
We even talked in post, and I showed him a
rough cut of the movie.
Then, we had conversations about 'is there
something here?'
We came to the conclusion of 'let's put a
pin in it.'
I'm all for finding opportunities, but I also
didn't want to force anything."
The remarks from both Johnson and Leitch,
plus the revelation from Morgan about having
had a chat with the actor, make it seem like
Reeves could appear in Fast & Furious 9 as
Eteon's Director.
But is that really how he'll fit into the
Fast family?
Anything's possible, of course, though it's
worth questioning whether that particular
role will ever be right for Reeves.
If it wasn't back then, how would it be now?
If Reeves truly will join Fast & Furious 9
and he won't portray Eteon's Director in the
film, the best bet for the type of character
he'll embody is an antihero similar to John
Wick, the hired gun Reeves plays in the Derek
Kolstad-created action-thriller franchise.
"Oh, and remember: You owe me."
"You don't want me owing you."
The Fast franchise has plenty of protagonists
- the most prominent of which is now Vin Diesel's
Dominic Toretto, and has featured a ton of
down-and-dirty villains.
But history has shown that the characters
who aren't entirely good or completely bad
are some of the more interesting inclusions
in the franchise, so it's possible that Morgan,
Casey, and Fast 9 director Justin Lin might
want to have Reeves play a morally gray character.
Considering the Fast & Furious franchise team
has long been eyeing Reeves to join in some
capacity, it doesn't seem outrageous to say
they'd want to place him in a role that is
not only interesting and well-rounded but
that also has true staying power.
Like Leitch said, Reeves' potential role in
the film series should have promise and legitimacy
so that he can continue being a part of the
movies in the future.
Taking everything into account, it appears
that Fast & Furious 9 just might be the movie
in which Reeves makes his franchise debut.
And regardless of who he may play in the flick,
his appearance should be, to quote the man
himself, pretty darn breathtaking.
"You're breathtaking!"
Fast & Furious 9 will speed into theaters
on May 22, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.